hello everyone and welcome to some more  disturbing news from the meltwater  Champions Chester Julius bear  Generations cup Magnus Carlsen was about  to play his game that everyone was  waiting for his game against Hans Mock  and Iman uh Hans had the white pieces  and after the initial moves the four  Magnus did play Knight to F6 but then  after uh Hans played C4 Magnus uh it was  in this position basically that Magnus  Carlsen resigned in the game and again  he's saying that he will not be playing  um  uh any games uh in the future it would  seem against the Han smoking Neiman why  this is so no one knows uh there are a  lot of a lot of guesses going around  it's very very odd but uh yeah it seems  that Magnus doesn't mind playing in the  same event as Hans but he will not uh  play against him personally so that's it  that's the news uh very weird stuff what  do you guys think about it uh let me  know in the comments uh see you see you  soon